hey here we go hey didn't you've never  seen one no I feel like I should have a  piece of cake or something okay ready  yeah yeah okay I'm gonna close the Bible  now Eddie it's supposed to be like that  it is I help you uh uh yeah what  happened to the school are you a parent  you're so hope not who you yanked your  beast look at you I guess you're a late  bloomer stop wait wait wait wait stop  please wait a second wait a second wait  a second could I be thinking mean stinks  in my blood  is it there it's there mm-hmm nomine  hazel grace take me all right here we go  yeah the one what haha now I know  exactly where the line in order no so  exhilarating huh oh stop if I were you I  would go back inside